all right hello hot breath the verse
welcome back to hot breath this is the
show where you learn comedy from the
pros
i'm your host comedian joel byers and we
here in the hot breath of verse are on a
mission
to cultivate the next generation of
great comics by interviewing
today's great comics and today we have
one of
if not the greatest comics ladies and
gentlemen
welcome to the show jeff foxworthy
everyone let's show him some love here
i was looking around to see who you were
gonna have on the show with an intro
like that
oh even even at the even at your level
you still have that mindset of like
i'm just a comic is that is that it
yeah wow i mean really
yeah it's uh it's
it's what i do and i'm not really
qualified to do a whole lot of other
things and so
i you know i i honestly have the thought
all the time crap i can't believe i got
away with this for this long
um and still happy to be here
so yeah yeah what what is it about
comics that
you love so much because you've i mean
i've i've seen you do
live q a's with comics here in atlanta
and like you really seem to enjoy giving
back and helping
like fellow comics on the on the upping
like the underdogs you know what is it
about comics
you know um i i i've always
said and i do a show on sirius uh called
comic mind and the first question i
always ask people is
are you born funny or is it a skill set
you can
acquire but honestly i believe you're
born this way
and i i believe it's a gift
and and some of us it takes longer to
discover it
than others but you can't
teach some you can teach somebody to be
a better writer i can teach somebody
how to shape their set better
but i can't teach somebody how to be
funny either you're funny or you're not
funny and so but but we're a little bit
weird
you know we don't we we often don't
excel in school
uh because we just got to get that
comment
in we're a little bit bold if you think
about it because
other people probably have the thoughts
we have but they don't have
the cajones or whatever to
blurt it out and so we're a little bit
weirded different and so when you meet
somebody you know it's like
the lizard going through the forest and
then he sees another one that looks like
him he's like dude
you know so that's kind of how i am with
comics it was like
there's an unspoken thing it's like yeah
you get it you know what it's like
who were some of your early mentors well
you can't politically correctly say it
now but obviously bill cosby
i mean it's a shame what he did socially
just nullified all of his professional
work because bill was an amazing
stand-up
uh just it's just a great storyteller i
was always fascinated that he
he could be clean and uh just still be
funny
bob newhart made me laugh with the
one-sided conversations
you know i used to watch pat paulson and
flip wilson then i graduated to carlin
and
richard pryor and um
you know used to watch dangerfield i
remember being a kid
and and peeking out of my bedroom my
parents would watch the tonight show and
i didn't care about the actors
and i didn't care about the musicians
but if there was a comedian on
i just wanted to watch them so i was
fascinated
with it from an early early age i would
buy comedy records and just
memorize them in a day you know go to
school do them and
obviously get in trouble but i i you
know so this thing was in my dna
yeah and even those early struggles of
being a comedian
like uh you know you're doing 400 shows
and making like eight grand
and things like that like that early
reality we're seeing you now
but there's a lot of newer comics that
watch this and listen to it like what
was your
early like struggle like
uh well it was hard to get stage time
you know you know i worked at ibm
for about five years and and only got
into stand-up because a bunch of guys i
worked with
entered me in a contest at the punch
line in atlanta
um i had no idea what i was doing i mean
i
i went and watched one week before the
contest started and
i went home and wrote five minutes about
my family
um and i won you know that
preliminary round the first night i was
ever on stage
and and i knew i knew a minute and a
half into it i'm like
holy crap this is this is what i want to
do i was scared to death but i
i knew this is what i wanted to do and
so then it was going up
every i mean i'd work all day and then
i'd go up any place
amateur night somewhere you know bar
with their wednesday night comedy night
it was just trying to get
stage time uh and i did that for about
three or four months and i quit my job
at ibm
and and got out on the road and
i honestly had no clue what i was doing
you know and i tell people often the way
you learn to be a comic is you hang
around with comics
because then somebody tells you oh
so-and-so has a gig
on the weekends here's his phone number
or
and that's how you learn to to write and
you find a group of
of friends that you know you kind of
share the same
um it's
kind of like us with a blue collar
comedy tour we all met
in the first year or two of when we were
doing comedy we now we didn't work
together all the time but we just met
and we found the same kind of things
funny
so i think you know 20 years later when
we came back together and did it that's
why it worked
uh or 15 years later because we found
the same kind of things funny we just
approached them from a different way
um but yeah man i the first year i'd
have the little
notebook calendar pocket notebooks i did
406 shows made 8 300
i think the next year i had eight years
in a row i did over 500 shows
so i was going on stage
every night i mean some places some
nights two and three places
uh the next year i did over 500 shows
and i think i
jumped to like eleven or twelve thousand
dollars that year
but you know in in in the rear view
mirror looking back at
it i i think
god it sounds egotistical to say good
but i think that's how i got
good was i was doing it every night
and then i'd go home i mean or go back
to the comedy condo or the motel or
whatever it was
and sit there and you know go this
didn't work
this work you need to build this up and
and so i had a work ethic about it and
when i looked back
most of the people that were successful
they worked at it they didn't
they weren't the ones i mean there were
some people that were just
naturally funny chasing the waitresses
all over the place but
but the people that long term did well
they worked at it it was their job and
it was important to them
and and and so i always kind of
approached it this way it was like
crap i don't want to be opening forever
i got to i gotta get better i gotta get
better and when i started middling i'm
like all right i gotta get better i'll
i'll do my time but i wanna make the
headliners
life a living hell i want the headliner
going to the club owner going
i don't wanna follow that guy anymore
that you know and
so yeah what is i always ask comics on
here like
their worst like like worst show they'll
never forget
i remember cedric entertainer was
talking about getting booed in front of
steve harvey
one time on here of like what is what is
one of those gigs or
some of the gigs that you've had over
your career where you're just like
man this is where you're really earning
your stripes like getting booed or
something thrown at you or anything like
that
i did a i did a
gig like an 85 i think it was some
somebody's company christmas party and
it was i did a couple of those i've done
those
yeah they were paying me they were joel
they were paying me 50 bucks so i
really needed the money and it was in
like an
old disco so it was like it had
octagonal dance floor and
it went up it was open like three levels
up
and so i get there and there's just
people eating hors d'oeuvres and
drinking it on in the middle of the
dance floor
they had a place where you plugged a mic
cord into the
mic back into the floor and so but the
mic cord they had was like four feet
long
and so if you took the tension out of
the mic
cord the thing would go you know just
feedback like hell and the guy walks out
there and he
never gets anybody's attention it's just
like in the middle of a party he goes
all right y'all we got a comedian for
you
you know the thing so i'm out there in
the middle of the floor
and i realize i'm like hey everybody my
name's jeff
you know the thing's feeding back and
nobody's listening i mean they're just
talking or you know nobody's
and so i'm doing this and i thought
this is awful not one person is
listening to me but i'm doing my time
you know i'm doing my 20 minutes because
i want that 50 bucks
and somewhere about five minutes into it
there were some drunk guys on the third
level
that started dipping their napkins in
their beer and they were leaning out
over the rail and trying to hit me in
the head
so now i'm contending with the mic cord
that's feeding back
and it's like so uh yeah by the time i
got to the store and picked up a
carton of milk
there's these napkins hitting the floor
and and i'm like this is awful so when i
get i do my 20
i get to the end set the mic down on the
dad
thank you everybody you've been great
thank you not one person clapped i had i
think they had no idea i had
finished and i walk off and i go to the
guy in charge
and i mean like your soul's ripped out
you know
you've and and i said dude can i just
get my money and go home
and he goes dude i'm sorry because we
we don't have any money i'm sorry i
don't know who set that
up and i said okay
i mean i didn't even argue with him
about it and i just
walked out and so yeah the horrible gig
and no money for the heart
how long after your career was that it
was about a year in
so about a year and it took you five
years to get on carson
yeah and like where how how important is
mindset of a comedian because that is
even like carson is something you had
been hearing
all right it takes you like 10 years to
get on carson and then you get in five
years and even like um
people wouldn't film blue collar for
instance or your book got turned down by
14 publishers it's like
how important is that mindset and that
resiliency and comedy
even at someone at your level one of the
highest achieving comics that
even you had to basically like forge
your own path the whole way
yeah i mean that's a great question and
and i do think it's
it's extremely important and you have i
mean
it's funny every every time i would run
into richard bell's or one night i was
early i mean i've probably been doing
comedy for three or four years and i'm
in new york when i
do an ascetic catch a rising star and
richard belzer
pulls me out of the lobby onto the
sidewalk and he's like
look he goes i'm not telling you how to
run your business
he goes those redneck jokes are stupid
you need to stop doing those they're
just stupid
and so you know for the next two decades
every time i would see him he'd go
pretty good advice i gave you about the
redneck right so
uh but but so in that case
instinctually i knew hey they may not be
the greatest thing in the middle of
manhattan
but i knew instinctually that
they resonated with a big group of
people
so i i think a lot of comedy is
being a comic you're trusting your
instincts on things
because you don't you don't know there's
not a
you know if if you work for a
corporation there's a career path and
it's if you do this then
then you move up to here and then if you
do this and
and and then in the creative world which
comedy is as creative as anything
there is none of that i mean i remember
asking older comics
what do i do how do do i how do i do a
book how do i
get somebody to to film me to do a
special
and and you get hell dude i don't know
i'm trying to do it myself i don't know
um so you are trusting your instincts
uh a lot of the time um
see i've already forgotten the question
now but yeah it's
pouring just like the mindset of a comic
with you
being turned down so many times but
still that resiliency
is like do you attribute that to so much
success you've had
yeah i mean i i mean i do you know and
it's
i mean i'm a nice guy i'm a really nice
guy but
but when it came to stand up
i would i i'd be nice to you all day
long
and i would do my time
but like when i was middling i
wanted to make your life a living hell
it i would cram 45 minutes into 30.
i i mean so there was a determination
and a mindset there
that because i knew i had to get better
i knew i was in the middle of a comedy
boom
but i knew it wouldn't last forever and
when it did
comics were going to be calling all over
the country saying hey you don't know me
but um and and i'm like i don't want to
do that i want to call and go
hey remember i was there six months ago
i need to get back
and so i made myself go out of my
comfort zones i didn't just stay in the
south
i made myself go to the north west and i
made myself
you know go to chicago being the dumb
ass southern guy
and so but i knew
i had to get better and so yeah i was
very determined about it i had kind of a
an attack mindset about it i guess
and when it comes to the business side
you gave us a good context for
how you were able to sharpen the skill
which i think is most important like
i've been doing comedy 10 years i didn't
even really think about
selling myself until maybe seven or
eight years when i felt like i had
something worth selling you know because
like you can get booked once
but the rebook is when you really start
to get
the traction and the money sure so get
that first opportunity it may be your
last if you're not ready
and you know and you know joel it's
it's it's show
business and everybody loves the show
there's a lot of people that don't
approach it as a business
so it's like when you're going into a
new club
don't be screwing up you know don't be
an ass
do your time you know keep the condo or
whatever don't
because you want to come this is your
business you are an entrepreneur and
your business is only going to succeed
to the level that you put into it
whether it's your act whether it's your
conduct off stage
whatever it is because they have
thousands of people to choose from
so what do you want to do to make them
go
that's who i want i want her i want him
to come back as opposed to all of these
other people and
and so yeah everybody loves the show
part the show part's great but the
business part
is what enables you to still be doing
this 10
and 20 and 30 years down the road and
in hell once i got a taste of it i'm
like i don't want to go back and sit in
a cubicle
you know this is the this is the
business i want to be in
what what kind of business tips do you
have for us comics
um you know marshall child's laughing
school in atlanta says it says something
i love it
he says you you need to spend time with
your material
and i've been doing comedy 35 years when
he said that to me
and i thought crap that's such great
advice
because the difference sometimes in a
joke being
okay or good or great is just a word or
two
or it's and and some of my favorite
nights in comedy was sitting there just
really as an observer in the back room
at the comedy magic club in hermosa
beach
listening to leno and seinfeld and
chandling
argue about the structure of a sentence
within a joke
and i was just sitting there watching
this going
if the audience could see this they
would be flabbergasted
to know this much thought goes into the
construction of a
sentence you know of jay going no it
should be blue and jerry's like
no jay green's funny or green
you know and i'm like
it sounds like crazy people but
i still do that like last time i'm
working on a new
game i wrote a 140 punch lines last
night
and then i and then i sat there and went
back through them like
moving words or cutting a word or
i mean there's there's a fine line
sometimes
between a good joke and a great joke and
and so and nobody else is going to do it
for you
again this is your business so
put in that time be intimate with your
material
you know think about and it's and it's
hard but think about
the way the audience perceives you not
your material but
you because if they don't like
you or buy into your point of view
then the material becomes secondary they
just like
i don't like him i don't like her um
and so yeah i mean there's a lot
of behind the scenes thing i mean to me
it's kind of like i've got a buddy that
plays football at the university of
georgia
he said hell game days that's the fun
part of the week for us
it's you know the practice
hell games are fun the the practice is
what kills you
well to me by the time i walk out on
stage that's the fun time
but because of all the work that went
into it before i walked out on stage
what what is your writing process and
has it evolved over time or has it kind
of been the same throughout
i mean it's it's it's it's evolved
i have uh oh my gosh
please yes share it all right well
all right so i just i'm sitting here in
my office i
i have that's the first handful
and there's probably seven other hands
full of notebooks just like that that's
just
that's just notebooks that doesn't
include all the scrap sheets of paper
and then
all right so like right here this is
this is the stack of these are all note
cards that's the stack i wrote last
night
uh those guys um
so it's kind of evolved from notebooks
to cards and
and then into the computer and it's like
as i write something
i usually will write it out long form
just
just as if as i'm thinking it and
in a notebook and then i'll take it from
that and i'll put it on a note card
usually editing some as i go and then
i'll take it from the note card and i'll
put it into the computer
you know the last time it may change one
or two things
like that hell i i i sometimes be
sitting in here and i'll just pull out
an old notebook and i'll be flipping
through it and go
crap that's funny why didn't i ever use
that you know why didn't i do something
with that
so um but it you know my kids laugh at
me because i still write
longhand but i will tell you comics
listening here's the advantage of
longhand and i know we live in an age
where it's all computers and phones but
i was
i was reading an article where uh
neurologists say
that if you write something with your
hand actually
write it out that you have a 70
better chance of memorizing it and
remembering it
than if you type it into a phone or a
computer there's something about the
action of your brain telling your hand
to
hey print this word out or
or whatever that makes you remember and
there's something i don't know why i
have the ability to do this
but as i write it then later when i'm on
stage i can almost see that page in my
head
like years and years ago i did a joke
about
uh about the side effects
of medical products that the side
effects were 50 times worse than
whatever the drug was supposed to cure
and so i sat down and i took a notebook
and i just wrote two pages of side
effects
and it was uh you know water weight gain
lower back pain receding hairline eczema
separia it's
shaving clothing liver spots blood clots
room worm excessive body odor uneven
tire wear
but as i'm doing this list on stage and
it's
you know 50 side effects i
i'm just reading it i can see that piece
of paper in my mind and i'm just reading
right down the piece of paper so people
like
crap how do you remember all that it's
like
i wrote it down and i can see it yeah so
if you have trouble remembering your
stuff on stage
try that take try whether it's note
cards or no
frightening physically writing it out
because neurologists say your brain
holds onto it better that way
so you'll like write long hand first
almost like free writing and then
read through that and pick what may be
funny and you take it and put it on a
note card
you kind of start to distill it down
that way yeah i mean i'll kind of free
form it and then i'll go back and read
it a couple
you know and i'll scratch this line out
or put an arrow and go i need to move
this here
and it'll it changes uh
you know it's i think in the early days
when i was on stage every night
i used to imagine it like i would have a
premise
you know four four jokes and go out and
try them and
three of the jokes worked or two of them
worked
good one worked okay and one didn't work
so the next night get rid of the one
that didn't work
you know see if you can change the one
that kind of worked
keep the two and then add two more and
so night after night after night it was
like
adding little pieces of clay to
something cutting the ones off that
didn't work but adding more
and over the course of a month you could
create
you know a new 10-minute bit out of the
thing just by
but now i'm not on stage every night and
it's
well now i'm not on stage ever oh
you're right we don't even want to
discuss that but
in a normal year not 2020 so i'm just on
stage on the weekends and so
instead of building it piece by piece i
would now
i tend more to glob it and then
go through it and just start cutting out
and it probably takes the same amount of
time to
to build up a bit but yeah i'll free
form it then i'll just start cutting
away or go i don't like this or you go
try something
one weekend and it doesn't work well
they go i don't you know
it doesn't matter if i think it's funny
or not the audience doesn't think it's
funny so
get rid of it um and
yeah so now i kind of maybe work
opposite but it's
kind of the same thing it's you know
it's clay adding and cutting away
and adding and cutting away and i
appreciate what you said about
if the audience didn't find it funny get
rid of it we can hold on to these
precious ideas
but if what is what is the response
editing can be so difficult i think
that's a great point
uh in his comics we're hard-headed you
know
here's what i used to say if if the if
the only people in the room laughing are
the other comics
get rid of it you know because we laugh
at [ __ ] nobody else laughs at
but i mean to this day and i mean you've
watched me work on new stuff i will have
things i'll put it on a note card and i
think
boy this is funny and you throw it out
there and you get
nothing yeah it doesn't matter
what you think the audience is always
right and it may be
hey maybe i didn't set it up right maybe
i didn't present it right
whatever but the audience is right hey
that's not funny and i don't
comics are like that we will hold on to
something
that it doesn't get a laugh and i'm like
why you know you've only got a certain
amount of minutes
you know holding that precious
microphone don't waste it
on something you're being hard-headed
about but they don't respond to
find you know chunk it find something
else
how do you deal with writer's block or
trying to generate
new ideas all the time um
i mean kylie me i've been through
periods in my life
where i thought i'm never gonna write
anything else i mean just
couldn't it it increasingly because i
started in 84
so this is my 36 year
i get writer's block less now than i did
even
15 20 years ago
but like writing these punchline cards
last night
i'm sitting there with my wife and she's
watching tv
but as she's gotten a little older she
puts the closed caption on so she can
read and that there was a show
set in ireland so she's watching closed
caption and literally as i'm watching
i'm just reading the closed caption
reading words
you know and a word might be
confused you know and i'm sitting there
going what's what's a joke i can do with
confused and it's
uh so it's just like little
pings to inspire me i think it's great
to have one or two other comics
that as you have these ideas that you
can
and you get stuck that that you can go
to these other people and go hey
is there anything funny in this idea uh
i have a buddy scott dunn who lives in
nashville that
we just write well together and
you know there's times that i'll go to
scott and say is there anything funny in
this he said
i don't know yeah he's honest or he'll
go yeah that's
that's a good premise let's see what we
can do with it you know so i'll write
jokes
and i'll send them to him and and he's
like
i don't like this part but i think
you're on the right track here and so
find somebody that
that you can that you can write with
writing that's all we are we're writers
people always ask me do you practice in
front of a mirror i said i've never
practiced performing
anything and performing is just
instinctual to me if i'm the kid in the
grocery store aisle
and a and i throw myself in the floor
and spin around that's not something i
practice it just
kind of just happened but the words
leading up to that
that's the heart i saw 25 years ago
steve martin won an award for
writing and he said out of everything
that he had won
you know academy awards or
golden globe he said this is the most
precious
award to me because writing is hard
wow right and and it is you
have to make yourself do it
you and and the blank page or the blank
computer screen
scares the crap out of all of us and so
you know nobody wakes up going boy i
want to write but once you
start once you get that first sentence
in or at least
i can only speak to me once i begin
then it just kind of comes i mean
it's one of my favorite quotes from
christopher titus he says i hate writing
but love having written
that's that's that is perfect yeah
that is right and i will tell you you'll
never find a great
comedian that's not a great writer um
so you want to be a great comedian you
better work on your writing yeah yes
and on the other side the business side
as well i do
we're about to start taking some
questions but i've i had to jump in with
some of mine first and i
i would be remiss to not dive into at
least your business sense
and i think it was larry i heard an
interview with larry the cable guy
talking about how you helped him with
branding and just thinking and comedy
and those terms
um what what kind of because it's like
the redneck jokes it was like five
minutes of a two-hour show
that now ended up becoming this empire
so like
what kind of branding tips do you have
for comics
well you know we're all
we're we're all unique um
i i'm such a visual guy but i always
used to say
it's like when you used to go to the
mall at christmas time
and you just drive up and down the
aisles i said you're looking for the
empty parking place that's always been
my business approach
i'm looking for the space that nobody's
in
um and so you know it's like a couple of
years ago i'll give you a great example
so
a couple years ago thanksgiving
every year at thanksgiving we have like
30 relatives at my farm
we've been doing it forever all the
cousins grandmothers
mom's dads and so the kids and i say
kids they're in their 20s now
but so thanksgiving night they're
sitting around the big table
and one of them pulls out cards against
humanity and they start playing cards
against humanity
which is hilarious but it's
also filthy you know it's just as dirty
as it can be
and i went over to him and i said you
your grandmother's here your aunts and
uncles are here you can't play this at
this table
you can play it but you know go
somewhere else because
and and i sat back down and i thought
well crap
and what makes cards against humanity is
there's no strategy you're just doing it
it's funny
and so i thought well there's got to be
a way to do this funny
that that grandma doesn't have to leave
the room and aunts and uncles doesn't
have to leave the room
and so i go in my office and i pull out
a stack of note cards
and i start thinking all right so what
what's a game you could play that would
be funny and
i i everybody's got a family that's why
we're here at thanksgiving as a family
everybody's family is crazy
so what if all i'd my skill set is punch
lines and set up so i wrote
a hundred setups involving relatives
and it was like you know right before we
walked down the aisle daddy leaned over
to me and whispered
blank so that would be a setup and then
i wrote
500 punchlines took me like the next two
days
and then i had them all all the aunts
and uncles and cousins sit down at the
table
and play the game on stupid note cards
and they were and i'm filming it and
they're laughing
and i'm like crap there's something here
because there's there's games of
strategy or whatever but to me if you
play a game and it makes you laugh
you'll play it again
then relative insanity ended up being
like the number one game on amazon
because it was just so that was a that
was a
looking for that empty looking for that
empty parking space
is there had to be a fun again there was
a funny game cards against humanity is
really funny
but the empty space was
your grandma and your aunts and uncles
couldn't play it because it was too
dirty and so it's
looking to go where's the where's a
niche that nobody is in
and it can be in a podcast it can be in
a game it can be in a book
you know it can be in a tv show there's
all kinds of empty spaces
but you know don't try to do what
somebody else is
doing make it yours
you're unique you you know find be
be true to i know tell comics that don't
try to you be true to your voice you'll
be true to your sensibilities
but look for those open spaces what's
somebody else not doing that
you can pull in there and do
and would it also be kind of like um
thinking of
like the the kings of comedy are working
but there's not that for this
demographic so is it also kind of like
cards against humanity has this audience
but not this audience were you thinking
the same thing with like blue collar
oh yeah the one of the first stops of
the kings of comedy
which was a tremendous comedy tour but
it was atlanta
and i'm reading an article about it in
the paper and it said this is a show
for the urban hip audience
and i called bill ingball and i said
look these guys are killing it
for the urban hip audience but that's
leaving a lot of people out because
there's a
i've been all over i've been every state
there's a lot of people that aren't
urban
and they're not help and i said we need
to do a show
for them and he laughed he said what
would you call it i'm like hell i don't
know call it the blue collar
comedy tour and um
and so again it's like you said i mean
there was an open space
there was nobody had done a group of
four people going after
you know middle class america and
we were going to do it for three months
and i think we did the first tour for
three years we had no idea it was going
to work
my gosh
it's it's it's almost overwhelming just
to think about the amount that you'd be
able to accomplish
all seemingly like just authentically
and organically it seems like
the whole time i think a lot of comics
we feel like there's like a system to
this to where we have to follow
a b and c and get this right agent and
this manager and get seen at this show
to get our success but i
and i may be assuming but it seems like
you've just
been putting in the work and through
that and being a nice person along the
way and that's brought a lot of
opportunity am i am i wrong in assuming
that
uh well i mean i you know i like to
think i'm a nice person
uh maybe somebody doesn't agree with
that
but yeah there is but you know joel
there's not
a yes does it do you good to get seen by
somebody yeah
but that's not the only path to do that
um there's there's no corporate handbook
that's that's why it's called creative
and so
if the normal ways don't work it's ours
we're we're the creative ones
you know the canvas is blank it was like
how do you
how do you do this you know i know
people that
couldn't get it going in comedy that sat
down and wrote a one-man show
and you know rob becker did that and
made a fortune traveling the country
with defending the caveman and and i'm
like man that was so smart that was
you know couldn't separate from the pack
in the comedy club so
do it from another way and so i think
it's on us to be creative
will it work to get seen by an agent
yeah maybe
but but there's also a ton of people out
there that have an agent that hate their
agent because their agent never gets
them anything
and yeah so we we've all it's
we're fighting for ourselves awesome
perfect well i've i've been fighting for
a lot of this time so we will
we will now um get some of the the hot
brethren and sisters questions
and i do want to candidly say my my
mouse has been frozen for like 10
minutes
so like this whole time i'm like trying
to fix the mouse so i can scroll over to
look at questions of people
so i i swear everyone i'm not i'm not
trying to hog your questions
i've literally been having technical
difficulties for 10 minutes and i just
slammed it on the desk hard enough to
fix it
say you were created you found another
way to do it
so um yeah we'll try to and thank thanks
for everyone tuning in we are at
about 95 right now people watching so
this is great
and probably primarily all comics jeff
so
cool awesome let's um let's try to do
some rapid fire here
people skipped work for this people like
i'm serious people as soon as i
announced it this morning
one uh one lady messaged me like well i
was going to start homeschooling today
but the kids can wait
yeah we're um we're really working to
like create that next generation great
comics in here we do a weekly
writing club we do these q and a's we do
writer's rooms like we're
we're really trying to make something
special here so we appreciate being a
part of it
let's see because there are some writing
questions
uh then we covered a lot of the writing
questions
um oh here we go uh this theodore
asks um what methods did you use to
establish
slash grow your following especially
outside of rural america
um you know i don't
i don't know that i had a message but
but what i was was i think i was
true to myself i i know when i first
started going to new york
the advice that i would get was people
would
pull me aside and go yo jeff you're
going to take voice lessons you got to
lose that stupid accent and
i'm like well you know where i come from
you have a stupid accent but
but my thought was and again it was just
instinct i'm like well at least a
quarter of the country talks
like i do so why would i try
you know why would i cover that up so
you know i i wasn't help i wasn't
sophisticated
and and so i just talked about the
things that i knew about
in my real voice and i kind of stayed
true to myself but i wasn't
i wanted to do it in a way you know leno
was so good
and you talk about passing the baton
leno
has been as good to young comics as
anybody ever
i remember you know one night in l.a
getting to meet
buddy hackett and uh milton berlin a
whole bunch of people
and somebody took a picture of him buddy
hackett sent me the picture and it said
to jeff grab the baton meaning
you're the next generation you know
we're in the relay race you take the
baton now
and so when i sit here and do something
like this i'm like sticking it back
going all right come on grab the baton
you run with it next
i've gotten to run with it for a long
time you run with it wow
um and um
so it's important to me to feed back
into it but
you know i i think i was just true to
myself a bit leno i know what i got a
point
leno said we're sitting there at a
waffle house one night at
you know one in the morning and and
leno says if you went clean you'll
always work
and someone goes what do you mean by
that he goes well you know you can't do
the tonight show and be dirty you can't
be
you can't do corporate shows and be
dirty well
hell i saw jay last year and and
i brought that up and he goes pretty
good advice when it worked out all right
and so and i'm not saying that for
everybody i mean i don't care if you
work blue or not i don't get offended
but for me i thought if i could be funny
and i don't have to be blue it
it widens the amount of people that can
listen to me
like you know and and i would say this
in front of ron
ron ron white i think is the most
naturally funny human being i've ever
met
in my life um but
ron's show my mom wouldn't go see ron
my aunt uncle wouldn't go see one
because he's too dirty live
well i look at that and go all right
what if i could be
what if i could do it in a way that's
still funny but they could come and so
again you know joel is probably more of
a business approach to it from
from my angle awesome yeah sounds like
jay would be a a good guest on here
jay would be a fabulous guest if you're
a comic out there listening one of my
on on sirius uh that the show that
that i do a comic mind i got to talk to
jay for an hour and a half
and it's funny for a lo
for a younger generation that never knew
jay is a stand-up comic
and just knew him as the host of the
tonight show you would have one
impression about him
i don't think i've ever seen a comedian
destroy a comedy club any more than jay
linda
back in jay leno's prime i i don't know
that anybody was ever better at stand up
than london
i think i feel like i've heard uh
seinfeld say that as well
i mean just destroy a room just
destroy like snot on the table
wiping your eyes destroy a room
oh there there's a few there's a few
comics asking about uh finding your
voice
how how did you able to how were you
able to find your voice and how long did
it take
um yeah and i guess by that you mean the
kind of things that i wanted to talk
about
or maybe your persona and yeah that it
feeds into what you're talking about
yeah
you know i remember being sitting there
one night
uh at the improv in la and and stephen
wright was really big then
and you know steve was very
slow and monotone but but so funny and
i just thought he was so funny and i
remember saying
man i don't know whether i should be
fast or whether i should be slow or
and and seinfeld said and i think you
just
do it every night and after 10 years
you have a style and i'm like
well i don't know about that but but
jerry was right in that in that like
when we did the first blue collar comedy
uh movie i had a joke in there
i was talking about a wood burning kit
and i would say
some about the back in the old days
people would inspect the toys to make
sure
there was no way a child could possibly
get hurt
using that using that thing and
and when i watched it i thought how i
didn't realize i did that to hit that
one word and go
up and
and i don't i hate to watch myself or
listen to myself but now i notice there
i that somehow
through just doing it that i do that
that there's a
you know there's a i will hit certain
words or pause a certain way and it's
it's not a calculated thing it's just
kind of how i've learned to tell a story
i guess
so it's something you kind of noticed
that got a response
and then you started to almost
incorporate it more into your
performance yeah i would think that's
probably you know
like uh like uh i was
talking to bob newhart one time and i
said i said you know what you can do bob
that i'm so jealous about
is you can make people laugh without
saying anything
you could just that pause
and he said well i stole that from jack
benny
you know jack benny you know the guy's
your money or your life
and benny yeah has to pause to think
about it yeah
and and so yeah i think i think we
do learn that it's you learn as you're
on stage working out
oh shoot sometimes if i take a pause
people start laughing or if or if i get
a manic they start laughing or whatever
it is
within your thing and i think over time
that's how your style develops
you know i'm sure it was that way with
kennison screaming i mean i
don't it probably wasn't a plan thing
just one night
and people started bursting and he went
oh that could actually
become a punch line that and yeah that's
how your style develops
so this is a good one about off stage
like balancing your life this is from
michelle van dusen she asks if
you still do your tuesday morning bible
group and if so
how do you balance touring staying
committed to them
and like you know she says balancing
your faith and career and your family
how yeah
what is that balancing act um
unfortunately i i haven't been able to
do it this year because of covet
so we've had yeah since february the
tuesday morning thing hadn't gone on for
the
as the atlanta mission um for homeless
guys but
you know michelle i i guess i would say
it's it's
the way you prioritize prioritize your
life
um and i always go back to several years
ago
somebody was interviewing me about
something and the lady said
she said okay you write books you paint
and you draw
you host game shows you do stand up
you act which one are you
and i said well those are all things i
do and i love
what i do i i feel like i'm the most
blessed guy in the world because
i made a fabulous living doing something
i i would have done it for free i i mean
i i would have that's how much i enjoy
it
but i said those are things i do it's
it's not who i
am who i am
is i'm a husband and i'm a dad
and i'm a son and i'm a brother and i'm
a person of this community
and i'm a child of god that's who i am
so what i do
may change many many times but
who i am hopefully stays consistent
across that thing
like one year like i would you know i
would i was lucky i had the financial
resources because of success
that i could do shows and then i i would
lease a little
private plane and i would fly home and
i'd get home at two in the morning i'd
take my kids to school i did that for 15
years i'd
fly to st louis do a show fly back to
atlanta get there two in the morning get
up at six and take my kids to school
and then that the next day fly to
minneapolis i mean that was just my life
wow but i grew up without a dad my dad
left and so for my kids more important
than in my career
i didn't want my kid because when your
parents not there you just feel like
you're not worth sticking around for
and i'm like all right no matter what i
do for a living i never want my kids to
feel that way
and so they were the priority so i just
found a way to work
you know around them i i learned you
know my dad was married six times i
i saw the destruction that left behind
and you know so when i was on the road i
was like
i'm not going out to the clubs i'm not
hanging out at the bar i'm finishing the
show
and i'm going back to my hotel room and
order room service
and be because i wanted
my kids to grow up with a mom and dad
that loved each other and lived together
so i was a husband and i was a father
and
but and so i'm so thankful that i've
been able to
be a comedian but i would have taken
much less
success as a comedian to be a good dad
or to be a good husband they were the
priority
yeah and that requires a lot of worth a
work ethic which matthew airby
is saying uh to quote the great ron
white
quoting you as saying i'm not the
funniest comic but no other comic will
outwork me
what what does that mean to you jeff
oh you know i mean it's
whatever your skill set is you know i
mean ron
ron could recap his day and
you'd be laughing so hard and i mean
it's like he hadn't even putting thought
into writing it down or
he's just where you're not gonna believe
what happened to me
this afternoon and and
you know it doesn't work that way for me
and but
but i knew i could be successful with it
works a good thing
i mean a balance to life is a good thing
but uh yeah you don't want to work too
much and you don't want to work too
little
but and so it's it's it's finding that
balance but work is
good for us because i i think we're all
born
with with a gift and with that gift
becomes our purpose
and and so i had this gift of being able
to make people laugh
and and the purpose of it you know i i
always said
i don't think laughter solves people's
problems but i think it's the release
valve that keeps the boiler from
exploding
and and you need that laughter as is a
momentary escape from the stress of life
and so
if i've been given this gift and my
purpose is to provide people that little
escape
then i'm actually being
not a good steward of that gift if i
don't put in the work
some people's gift is taking care of old
people some people's
gift is you know carving up
meat some people's get i mean it doesn't
matter what your gift is
when when you
don't put in the work to be good at that
and honor that gift
then you're not living up to the purpose
that you're here for
so let's get we got a little celestial
there i'm sorry
no no it's beautiful no we like we like
covering all the bases here
at hot breath i'm just uh want to get
uh she's posed this question a few times
and i think it's i think this will be a
good one in terms of
in on the same track as finding your
voice or finding material that's unique
to you
this is robin sutton clark um
basically her persona is a hot piece of
white
treasure trash it's like she she has
like trailer jokes and things like that
and um it's seemingly like the jit it's
all
it's like a paragraph but i think the
gist of the question is basically like
how can i
create my own unique material about
her life and like like i guess more of
like redneck life
but without like feeling like she's
stealing from you
oh i don't think you know i don't ever
look at it that way
is stealing from me you know the whole
redneck thing was
it was a formula it was one-liners in an
age kind of where nobody did one-liners
but but it was also talking about a
subject
that i i didn't have to research it was
my freaking relatives yeah if you have a
complete set of salad bowls and they all
say cool whip on the side that's my
sister you go
you go to her house right now there's
cool whip bowls and jelly glasses
in the counter uh so
you know in a case like that i would
i wouldn't worry about that to be
because
if this is your life if this is the
thing you know about
then that's that's the lane you need to
be in
um you know you may sit there as you
write with it and i do this sometimes
when i get stuck
as is i will try to put
like like oh my god
i think on the second album i did i did
a whole bit about
the clampett's go to maui and it was
about me taking my relatives
on vacation which i did i took everybody
in my family to hawaii
so as i'm sis and i
there were some things that they
actually did that are part of the thing
but i also put in there i write down
everything you can think about about
hawaii on one side of the thing so it
was like hula dances
grass skirts coconut bras right and then
on the other side i would say what
what did my relatives do they steal
stuff they yell stuff out they
and and that was able
to like write a joke i said one night we
went to a luau
and you know my uncle got up to do the
hula dance
and we all realized halfway through the
dance he's not wearing any underwear
underneath his hula skirt well that was
just
taking column one and column b and just
crisscrossing and go
how can i so in the case of the white
trash trailer girl
you know think of different scenarios
put her in la put her in new york put
her in the department store
and then list the department store and
then list the the traits
and that's where it starts getting fun
and funny and you know that whole thing
i i i think ron thinks that or larry
larry's the one that thinks the
clampetts go to maui is the one of the
funniest things i've ever written
um
but yeah when you get stuck that's a
great little writing thing
is you know i remember doing a routine
about
men cleaning up the house and how we
have to get
credit for every little thing we do when
we clean up the house
and but i was stuck and so i wrote
everything traits of men and then
what do you do when you clean the house
you vacuum your dust you wash dishes
and then other what do men do we you
know
and and just start crisscrossing them
and looking and going can i connect that
to that can i connect evident
and and that is a beautiful way to plow
material
right there um wow
it works it worked 30 years ago it still
works
yeah and how do you how do you um start
to shape your
hours because i know you're you're
preparing for a netflix special
or you were at least um like how do you
then start to
oh that hurts joel i haven't been on
stage since march i'm like i'm like
feeding for it so oh yeah it's like yeah
it's been a it's been a
new a new era for sure but um a lot of
people are asking about how
you have all these great jokes but then
how do you start to shape it into like
an hour-long
set um i actually sat down and
this is the scariest thing after all
these years this is still scary for me
to get to the point where
and i've done it six or seven times in
the course of my career
where i go all right i'm not doing
any of this stuff anymore and i'm
starting from scratch
which to do
to to have an hour and a half that's
getting a standing ovation
and to go i'm not doing it anymore uh
and i'm gonna start from scratch it's
just
terrifying what because you know how
much work you're gonna have you know
you're right back to the 20 people in
the club on monday night with a handful
of note cards going is this funny
is this funny um so like in create but i
did that again
trying to create this netflix special uh
and you know it's gonna be painful you
know it's gonna be hurt but there's not
there's not a shortcut to it there's
if there was an easier way to do it i
would find it but there's just not
and so you know like in the case like
that i had
um two or three different
subjects i thought that i wanted to talk
about and so i was kind of writing
towards them and i will say that's one
thing that's changed
and that's the beauty of reaching the
point in your career where you have an
hour and a half to play with
as opposed to six minutes is
obviously the bits have gotten longer
so you know what was
you know five years into doing comedy a
long bit would have been an
eight-minute bid now it might be a
30-minute bid
and and so over the course of trying to
shape this thing it changed several
times and i mean there was one area
that i really felt like i wanted to talk
about that i couldn't make work i just
couldn't
make it work but there was kind of a
secondary offshoot off of another thing
i wanted to talk about and went oh
that's funny and so
you know for this new hour and a half
it's probably three subjects four tops
um so and and i'll look at that go oh
that's kind of weird i wouldn't have
back in the old day i wouldn't have
written
you know a 30 minute three thirty minute
minutes but
it's just the way it worked out that's
why i've heard chris rock say that too
he basically talks about the three same
things and just breaks up his set
into like chunks on each of those
subjects
and that's you know i mean that's a
luxury because you've got
the big length of time to be up there to
do that whereas
you know even say you're doing a
six-minute set you're picking your best
jokes
even if they're not necessarily
all related to each other or
but but having a longer amount of time
gives you more time to
expand on things and and kind of dig
deeper you know and i always tell comics
that
another writing tip
the part the setup
is necessary you cannot do it without
the setup did i lose you
oh i'm here no i can't see you
uh oh you can't can you see me
i can see you you look okay i can see
that mustache in all its glory
um but you have to do the setup
and but once you've put in that work the
setup's not getting you a laugh it's the
setup
once you get the punch line it drives me
crazy to see a comic that will do a long
setup
and get a laugh and then move on to
another setup and i'm like
crap you've put in the work now that
you're you've got it set up
instead of getting one laugh really go
look at this thing and say
you know is are there two laps here are
there three laps here are there four
laughs here
because you've set it up you know
and and so learn to dig deeply you know
the terports critical thinking thinking
to the next level the next level on the
next level
and but and that's how bits grow longer
so if you've got a funny premise and it
gets a good laughing you
then start thinking all right can i stay
here a minute is there
is is there more to dig out of this hole
um and and that's how a funny joke
turns into a bit turns into holy cow
have you heard her
15-minute bit on the grocery store or
whatever
yeah so yeah man be conscious as you're
writing
all right i've done the work i've set
the joke up
are there more laughs that that i can
get while i'm at this spot
how do you find those laughs is it
asking questions is it looking for
funny analogies yeah what do you do to
find those laughs
i mean sometimes sometimes it's
analogies
again you know like for me i might write
the word down like you know anything the
kid in the grocery store
and then i start you know again i'll go
what do kids do in a grocery store
well you know they grab stuff off the
shelf they beg for stuff
they you know they and and so i'll just
start writing that down and and
and and just seeing all right if i can
take this i got a funny joke about this
but
can i get two more jokes can i get three
more jokes out of this and now i've got
a whole bit i don't want just have a
joke i got a whole bit
about this and but for me that's what
works as i just write it down on a piece
of paper and i'm like
just everything associated with it our
analogy is great too
but um or here's what kids do
here's what is in a grocery store make
two columns and just start
trying to connect the lines
but that's how you get to be a more
expansive writer
and and and jokes turn into stories
which is
really cool too awesome well
this this has been really cool jeff um
thank you so much for taking the time to
do
this um yeah this is amazing people yeah
people are
now people are making mustache comments
now that
i used to have a mustache and um i i
hosted for louis anderson
super early in my career on a bonkers
gig great gig
and it was um i had a mustache
and he was like i used to have a
mustache he's like do you want to be
known as a
a comedian or you want to be known as a
comedian with a mustache
and then like the next show i did after
his right when i walked out i just heard
someone yell
mustache and i was like wait maybe this
is a sign to shave it i didn't realize
but like it was like a bizarre moment of
like me hearing louie anderson say this
and then the next show
it's like an example of someone yelling
mustache at me i was like oh maybe i
should shave it but
yours stand strong i don't i
you know when kovitz started i've been
married 35 years my wife had never seen
me without it and so
i actually shaved it off uh i and i
didn't tell anybody i just went in and
shaved it off and
i walked out and she looked at me and
she goes oh wow all right grow it back
so she's seen me one time without a
mustache but
now you're making me think i don't want
to be known as the comedian with the
mustache
but you're not no you're jeff foxworthy
no no not at all
i was just saying you you were able to
like
surpass that like for me as a newer
comic all they see is mustache and
they're like oh mustache and then
what was his name but i mean no you yeah
you're
you're by no means a mustache then
comedian you're a comedian
you're a father you're a son of god
and then maybe a mustache
it was so funny when i shaved it off my
daughter took a picture of me put it on
instagram
and people were like no no
no no no you are supposed to have a
mustache
so i'm like all right i grew up back
well i know you're about to actually go
um interview colin quinn on your show
which is amazing i'm serious
um if you guys love hot breath you'll
love his serious show it's it's we're
right of the same
comedy ilk there um do we always in
these
with uh two things the first one is what
is your favorite
closing advice like for comics what is
the best advice you ever heard or advice
that you could bestow upon this next
generation of great comics
um you know it it's probably a little
bit of what i said before but but if but
if you have this gift
you you obviously have if you're
watching this
you you've got this thing in your heart
that comedy
makes you sing but but if you've been
given this gift it's it's an
honor to have this gift
and you become a steward of this gift
and so use it well use it use it wisely
don't take it for granted it's
you know i i after all these years i
look back and i go there's
nothing else i would have rather
done for a living nothing
else and you know i'm not alone in that
you look at
look at how much money seinfeld has or
leno had when they're still out there
doing stand-up i mean
you if you're a comic you're a comic
it's
your comment because you can't have i
mean that's that's who you are so just
honor this thing
and you know it's growing up a country
boy i bought a farm about an hour south
of atlanta and i always thought
you know i never looked at it and
thought i
owned this what i think is
i've been given stewardship of this for
just a little while and it's my job
to leave it better than i found it for
the next person
and so
like for me to even do this show
my heart in it is is is i want all of
you watching to be great comics and i
want
for you 20 30 years from now
to be doing somebody else's show
for the next generation because it's it
is a gift and it's a valuable gift and
you look at
you know the world right now especially
like this year
the the thing that's missing is laughter
we've lost the ability
to laugh at ourselves we just yell at
each other
and and the medicine
for a lot of the the animosity and
and hatred that's going on right now is
to just
i mean we're all we're all screw-ups
we're all screwed up we're all doing the
best we can to get by so have grace with
people
and you don't know what their struggle
is but learn to laugh at yourself like
you don't you
when you have to be right that means
somebody else has to be wrong
and people get tired of being wrong and
they walk away so
give up your right to be right just be
kind be funny
and and use this gift that you've been
given
be kind be funny hot breath verse and uh
the the final thing here if you don't
mind looking into the camera
and just letting people know who you are
and why they should listen to hot breath
uh this is jeff foxworthy uh comedian
and a bunch of other stuff and the
reason you should listen to hot breath
it's four out of five
i know and i always always take pride in
being one take jake
i am comedian jeff foxworthy and you
should listen to hot breath because four
out of five dentists
will assure you it gives you stronger
brighter teeth
all right ladies and gentlemen jeff
foxworthy everyone give it up for jeff
foxworthy one time
absolutely amazing jeff thank you for
sharing your time
um yes we're gonna get out of here hot
breath the verse jeff is gonna go
prepare for his
his show now so is there anything you
want to promote jeff before we get out
of here
um no no i gotta promote y'all to just
go out there and write
go right right right right right
beautiful
right right right right right and be
kind hot breath the verse we'll see on
the next q a
bye
hey hop brother and sister and thank you
so much
for tuning into this honestly thank you
thank you thank you for spending your
morning with me here
and jeff absolutely amazing i'm sorry to
get to all your questions
i tried my best but we really got a lot
of good tips out there
so thank you so much for being a part of
uh the hot breath verse
and please share this share this live q
a post and other facebook groups share
it on social media let
let people know that hot breath is out
here
and um we will see you soon
oh and i'm actually going to record the
outro for the podcast
now that i'm sitting here
um there it is hot breath the verse if
you want to get involved in more of
these q and a's
go join our facebook group we also have
a private facebook group called hot
breath pro
where you can get q and a's with me we
do workshops in there we do our own
writing rooms in there if you want to up
your writing game like jeff was talking
about that'll be linked in the show
notes
and i hope to see you in there but until
next monday
right here on hot
breath oh
all right hop brother and sister and
thank you for all the kind comments
we will see you tomorrow in the right
ten club i'm so excited
i love you all so much we'll see you
then bye